so you guys saw anthem yesterday I saw
it last week what you guys think that's
a very broad question and I have a lot
of thoughts to be honest today yeah
something a lot of people have a lot of
thoughts on this game yeah it's I mean
going into it I was expecting like
alright it's gonna be kind of destiny
like formula with some like cool stuff
applied to it mostly an Iron Man stuff
yeah and that's exactly what I got out
of it for better and for worse it's also
exactly what I'm a made my guy look like
is Iron Man yeah it's exactly what Peter
made this guy look like - let's look at
what Peter made here so we can just get
some of the highlights highlights I
definitely spent a lot of time in the
character creator customization stuff a
lot of time there's a lot there and it's
kinda prizing because you think about
destiny which is like there's so much of
that cosmetic element to it and like
shaders and stuff like here it just
seemed to open like you have the four
classes you can pick from the ranger
that interceptor the storm and the
Colossus and then from there you can
customize the nitty-gritty yeah but
those four classes honestly those feel
so different I feel like that's kind of
like I think we must hit on you know I
think for all of us like we we each
picked one of the four classes in our
group of four you know who got stuck
with the Colossus well Jordan was
playing classes in it and I think he
liked it quite a bit
eventually Rob transitioned to it he was
it was different
yeah I couldn't get anyone to play storm
but I loved playing so really storm was
one of my favorites when I played that's
what I thought too
what was it for you that did it I mean
just the you don't use your guns that
much at least the build that I had I
didn't use my guns I was mostly like
freezing people and then I'd combo that
with like another move that would cause
of reaction or his ultimate or its
ultimate where you just like drop
elemental damage onto the field I
thought was pretty cool it was awesome
like I think in the literal sense of the
word like he was a sort of thing I was
like dang that's powerful and this game
looks good when I'm doing that yeah I
also felt a little detached playing as a
storm like from the action yeah almost
because I couldn't see after I was like
sending out all my magic what was
happening you also he's the only that
can hover infinite yes well almost
infinitely which
which is yeah like but that plays into
what I really love about this game which
is the flight so I had a really good
experience with storm but it also
definitely tainted how I felt engaged in
the action but I didn't want to stop
playing as storm that said it's kind of
neat to see that like play out with the
different javelins right cuz like I
think on the other end of the spectrum
Colossus can barely hold his own and
before you have starts overheating right
I feel like you start really consuming
heat or however you would say it when
you're stationary right when you're
hovering in hover mode so clausus is
very grounded like artillery type of
yeah he's interesting too because he's
the only one I believe that doesn't have
a regenerating shield so really at least
at least the build I played he didn't
have regenerating shield so that meant
you had to play aggressively to pick up
health pickups in order to stay right in
the fight but I'd find myself like
especially after paying playing storm
and interceptor I'd find myself like
backing off and waiting for a long time
and then like realizing oh wait I
actually have to be in there which was
interesting I think he felt the most
different out of all of them but I
didn't play the Ranger nor did I I heard
people saying that it was maybe a bit
too basic yeah baby yeah there just
there wasn't like that identifiable like
oh that makes this experience feel
special
[Music]
if there is one really awesome thing
about this game is how how it feels and
how controls right the flight and within
an hour I felt like I was I'd say unless
dude we were all right within minutes
yeah we were just soaring through the
sky without I could figure out the
rhythm of like fly near a waterfall
flying near water like get it up and
then you can just keep going and going
and going if you know you're but I guess
we will try say is it's the moment a
moment of switching from you know
probably three different states of you
know activity right like like like
beings to hover mode yeah there was bad
hover mode flying and then being on the
ground right so like the the transition
of like flying
- like hover I really loved how quickly
like you know your sensitivity and like
the I guess call it like dead panning
right of like how quickly you could spin
around in hover mode like all that it
felt really really good and it made me
excited because like this morning I woke
up I was like dang I kinda want to like
fly around again but you have a game
that gives you that feeling yeah think
of like as everyone is saying oh it's a
great Ironman game it almost feels like
a superman game like with the the way
you fly around yeah it's pretty cool it
makes the scenarios pretty interesting
too because you're not really like I was
talking about the division and how I
don't really know how I'm gonna play the
division - after this just because this
is so freeing and like I'm not sticking
the cover and like sneaking up on
someone it's just like alright I want to
flank and you just take off and fly over
them yeah toward the end we started to
see some of that really cool dynamic
cooperation with each other we're like
someone is just you know maybe the
Colossus for instance one of his
abilities is just to lure enemies
towards him as a distraction right I
take all the hits and someone could go
underwater or like you know go around
and flank and all the verticality there
it was like was really great you could
really see like a nice cooperative
rhythm with with people but I don't know
I guess those are some of the highlights
yes
we struggled coming out of this yeah I
think to be really enthusiastic and it's
because I think all of us really enjoyed
the moment-to-moment
feel of game play regardless of the the
you know the the suit that we were
commanding but at the same time the
mission objectives and the things you
had to do to complete those felt way too
rote and similar unimaginative and it
kind of felt like going through the
motions a little bit you know just thing
that reminds me of destiny right that's
just it and like and I came into this
thinking like well you know destiny was
something I was able to stick with for
maybe close to a hundred hours but I got
sick of that grind because it started
started to ask myself why am I doing
this an anthem I saw like okay this
mobility this movement you know the way
that you can act like that all seems to
be the thing that would really draw me
in and it does but I don't know if it's
gonna do it long term and I'm really
skeptical if I even want to play this
game now yeah I mean I will say cuz my
it sounds like my demo is a little bit
different and I played a stronghold and
that strongholds are basically like
strikes and this and that definitely I
thought was more interesting but what I
need to know why well I I mean it like
not so much of the objectives but just
like you fight a big boss that looks
really cool and there's it's much harder
so it least feels like you're you know
working together strategizing trying to
figure out what works best what builds
work best and I think that's kind of
where the interesting stuff comes like
we when I played some of the story yeah
I was thinking the same thing but like
it's I guess I mean if anyone likes that
stuff that's wonderful I give it I want
the unexpected right I want to know that
oh it's not just more difficult because
they've dialed things up right I I
didn't get a sense that this game has a
huge well of surprises in store for me
it just almost immediately felt familiar
yeah which is scary for a game like this
that supposed to be so different
that's enough impressed and if there's
one thing that I want to see more o cuz
I mean I'm still like kind of lukewarm
as a whole on this game like I still
want to see what's there to offer like
as far as loadouts and like messing
around with different like types of
abilities so like that like for the most
part I mean again I guess I played
Ranger which is a very you know just
kind of straightforward class in itself
but just seeing like yeah that was
messing on with poisoned darts or like
seeker missiles like I only got I feel
like just surface level stuff and I'd
like to I'd like to like because that's
kind of like the essence of like
whatever the end game is right it's like
messing around with loadouts and stuff
yeah I mean I'm I'm pretty curious about
the story because it is Bioware and I
know like I'm not sure how much of the
story you guys saw but from what I saw
there were some really well-done
cutscenes and really good writing I
think this story itself was kind of like
at least like the plot was very like
like heavy with things like oh the
anthem and like the the pronouns yeah
there was just like a bunch of pronouns
that I was like I don't I don't really
care about this I just wanna know about
the characters and when you I don't know
how much time you guys spend for tarsus
we it's like the Normandy it feels a lot
like the Normandy and that you walk
around you talk to people you do have
some dialogue options not as deepest
like Mass Effect or Dragon Age but I'm
curious to see where they go with those
characters because that is like at the
end of the day why a lot of people play
Bioware games me included so I'm curious
to see if that at least kind of drives
me to do these sort of you know like
what you're saying these rope missions
where you just go to this thing plant
this talk to this person I agree with
you and I think that is very engaging
though what is at the fort Tarsus right
like everything there seems neat with
like even you know you despite them
being like one or two like dialog
prompts it's it's engaging enough what's
where I'm a little skeptical and fearful
of is that feels like a single-player
game and then what we were also doing
was a multiplayer game and I think those
have a hard time meshing and it's
that point being like you look at some
like destiny right like where it's like
you and I could play the whole campaign
campaign like in one sitting together
seamless Washington that scenes at the
same time where this game I think will
have a major setback is differentiating
and and and the coordination involved
with story so for instance when we were
playing like the first hour and a half
ish
I think we did like two or three
missions every time we ended on when
these campaign expeditions were asked to
either go back to forage which is a menu
or go back to port our support arses is
a single-player feature right like you
just walk around and you were asked to
like talk to people that's so rip that
rips you from any kind of multiplayer
element and that's what's fearful is
like we we hit that like three times or
it was like okay guys I guess what
you're waiting for people because people
are like still talking or I just saw
people do things I was like wait how are
you doing this I didn't even realize
like the game should have told me
something like hey the story's happening
lately I mean to be fair there were
waypoints right but like it didn't feel
like we were experiencing that
transition out of a mission and into the
next step of the story together like if
I had seen them running off to go talk
to a guy I probably wouldn't have like
started looking at my loadout for a
while and stuff like that but but we
were all so detached from one another
that there was never a sense of
cooperation outside of missions and I
have to say as well to go from this free
flying fast moving hard-hitting warrior
to someone who can't even jog in the in
Tarsus it's so frustrating you have to
walk so slowly to get from point A to
point B right now granted they kick you
back to where you want to be if you want
to look at your stuff or go out on your
next mission but this thing is supposed
to expand and get bigger and entice you
in different ways to explore the city if
I have to walk to and fro that is just
it's really frustrating we were all
sitting there like this is it's and it's
not utilized well because I think you
know it's a change of pace I think
that's like you could see that dynamic
or that contrast or it's like okay I've
just been I've been flying around and
have been tearing a band-aid off though
like there's yeah there's no amount of
like giving you agency over like what
that's what saying is like it should be
to a level of like optional like okay
it's time to take a break I'm ready to
like dive into the story but in those
early campaign hours it's
mandatory right like you're being forced
I have to talk to this person like
there's nothing more problematic in my
opinion than than what we were doing
which was like okay we just want to play
you we had this happen I'm skipping
through dialogue yes my drive is to
continue play because I had a really
pretty great time that last mission I
want to keep going I want to like get
right back into it I found myself
wanting to skip through some of the
story stuff too but like I was just like
all right I'm here at this preview event
I just wanna play this game I don't
really care about the story right now
like for me I know that when it actually
comes out I will probably get more
invested in that and I probably won't
mind sitting through that I tried to sit
through it I tried to get that story in
the beginning but like you said before
it doesn't do it's not compelling it
doesn't do anything that's what I'm
saying part of it is that just being at
a preview event like the nature of being
at a preview kinda like I was like I
disagree I think it was just poorly
poorly handled as an intro to make you
care because I wanted to care about the
story I conflicted important I would I
would gladly replay it again to give it
that that second chance because I wanted
to I I would I would agree with you I
mean at least for me I was kind of I
kind of felt like I was distracted like
worrying about pairing up and playing
with you guys where I guess the point
being that I would play this game at
launch by myself just a campaign that's
what I'm thinking of and then I would
and then I would hit up other people to
play with like that's for sure I plan to
play this because I'm I'm I'm definitely
still interested in this game but yeah
yeah cuz I like I want to take my time
around for tarsus I don't really want to
like have people waiting for me or be
waiting on other people as they're like
oh I still have to talk to this person
and some of those conversations are like
three minutes long and it's like alright
I guess I'm just gonna like look at my
javelin for a while or like spin circles
and yeah and that's kind of a bummer but
it's also kind of how I how I wanted to
play destiny in a way was just to like
experience it myself I like that story
work well I'm sorry
destiny - sure people said that story
was better and what about you that's too
bad I wanted the power I'm not saying
the story was like it spectacular but I
still wanted to like
appreciate it or try to well yeah I
think that's what we all want but I
don't think anthem really I'm just
saying I tried to pay attention to my
best I was not like I'm at a preview of
n get me through this I tried to give it
a fair shake and I was like this is just
another one of these games with the
thinnest flimsiest justification for why
I am there for Who I am there's no sense
of character there's no sense of
belonging to that universe like they try
to tell you like oh man remember we
weren't freelancers we treated like gods
it's like no I don't like I'm just kind
of here now and no one likes us and I'm
expected to do everyone's dirty work
okay what a great life well I can't wait
from high preview I liked it quite a bit
I'm looking forward to it I had a lot of
fun with the gameplay I was intrigued
with this story but yeah like some of
the intro stuff was like I thought
pretty weak but it sounds like you guys
are kind of like middle of the road yeah
I don't think I want to play it I will
play it I'm yeah I pardon me just wants
to like do all that again just to have
like a solidifying opinion because I'm
like up in the air in a way I'm I'm less
excited about it yeah
up in the years ago way to put it in for
a game like this
you